and here I am dressed in my Sunday Best
to bring you the list of the top 10
worst movies of 2022 because we're all a
sucker for that equal and opposite
reaction if I do a video of the top 10
best like I do a video of the top 10
worst it was funny the top 10 worst
videos have become more difficult to
narrow down than the top 10 best because
these past couple years maybe a few
there's been some movies where I'm like
that that doesn't look good that doesn't
look interesting I'm gonna skip it this
happened quite a few times these past
couple years the top 10 worst ends up
being top 10 worst slash most
disappointing also these are not reviews
these are going to be a quick hey here
are my thoughts quick thoughts let's
move on I have reviews of all of the
movies on this list if you want to see
my more in-depth thoughts you can check
out the reviews the one is I've narrowed
it down to 10 I don't want to keep it
too long so let's get started but
supplies we need supplies supplies
there we go
that should make it better I don't know
if my fellow single malt fans have had
lagavulin but it's nice and Smoky which
makes sense for this video because
we're about to burn some trash number
10.
starting out this list is a movie that
pretty much started out the year it came
out in January possibly early January
point is the 355. it's one of those
movies I had largely forgotten about
until I was making my list that's that's
the give and take I still love and hurt
that's the the Pleasure and Pain of
doing this video your brain worked so
hard to forget garbage and then you're
making your laser like what's the oh
yeah for oh wow I'd forgotten all about
that that's right that action movie with
horribly framed action sequences and
shaky Cam that movie that felt like an
action film from 20 years ago not in a
good way not in that way of homage but
in a way that makes the top 10 worst of
the year list anyhow I'd forgotten about
this movie until now and I'm gonna
forget about it again in three two one
number nine
next up what happens when humor works in
your franchise in your Cinematic
Universe and then you take the humor to
such an extreme that it feels like an
SNL sketch parody of itself you get Thor
11 blunder Thor 11 Thunder it was it was
the line it's like okay don't let your
MCU movies get this silly rain it in
stop with that mindset of oh humor works
great we'll do all the humor that's like
having a recipe for something it's like
oh sugar makes it sweet great let's
let's be like Def Leppard and pour all
the sugar no balance is what makes
something work and if humor is a part of
it great this was just ridiculous I saw
this comment it's almost like man this
is this movie hurt Jeremy back no it
didn't I'm just talking about it my top
10 worst movies of the year list while
drinking Scotch wearing a robe
everything's fine number eight next up
the Rob zombie monsters truth be told I
thought this movie would be higher on my
list but there are other movies on this
list that disappointed me more I suppose
I should say and maybe that's the point
I had no real investment with this film
I had no connection with the monsters
and this movie is clearly a love letter
to the monsters you see it I get it not
for me this is one of those movies that
looks bad and I would have skipped but
it was it was on Netflix I was like I
don't have to go anywhere I can just
watch it here still took me two sittings
I get the love letter but Rob Zombie
isn't a comedic writer and director
there are some actors in this movie that
are trying their best to make it work
but they're just
this is one of those movies I was like
I'm I'm one and done on this one number
seven
pack stop okay
the gotta love the memes
the year that's going to be remembered
as the year in which it was morbin time
but that morbius movie is not good come
on a live-action Michael morbius film
could have been great epic even he's a
living vampire but I walked away going
yeah that is the studio that brought us
Venom let their big car in it just like
a bad comic book movie from about the
mid-2000s again not in that homage kind
of way just in the way where it's like
morbius took me back
in all the bad ways number six next
I just realized this is it's like this
is the list of movies that throw back in
all the bad ways take bad video game
movies for instance or Uncharted from
this year yeah it's on here look we all
love the actors in this movie no
disrespect to them but you have Tom
Holland acting like Tom Holland and Mark
Wahlberg acting like Mark Wahlberg but
we're supposed to buy them as Nathan
Drake and Sully because the movie's
telling us that's who they are also
there's a really stupid villain flip in
the last act it's nothing about this
movie work for me everything enjoyable
in this movie you can actually play in
the games and experience it in more epic
fashion it's a film that doesn't do what
this film needed to do which was justify
its own existence number five next up
what are we on what number five dead
center Fire Starter there's a new Fire
Starter movie did you know that no did
you forget yeah me too I haven't read
the book I've seen comments in the
comment section of my review where
people were like I've read the book and
this is not it this is terrible which
means if you've read the book this
movie's bad and if you haven't read the
book like me the movie's still bad it's
a tonally uneven schlock ass mess of a
film you see potential of what they
could have done in the film which I
guess is what Stephen King did in the
book again about as forgettable as three
two
number four what was I just talking
about right forgot but also there is
Texas Chainsaw Massacre do you remember
that there was a Texas Chainsaw Massacre
movie that came out this year no I know
a lot of these movies are really
forgettable I'm just I'm at the point
where I'm like stop making bad remake
Wolves of Texas Chainsaw Massacre this
is at least the second time not counting
the whole reboot that they did with
Jessica Biel back in the day but in
terms of canonically wiping out all the
sequels and making the first true sequel
this is at least the second time they've
done it Texas Chainsaw 3D do you
remember that actually I do it's more
memorable than this Texas Chainsaw movie
or sorry Texas Chainsaw Massacre not The
Texas Chainsaw Massacre and not Texas
Chainsaw these are different movies I'm
just saying in a Texas Chainsaw Massacre
movie I'm not supposed to root for
Leatherface I was like
kill them all who cares
at number three all right so here's the
thing about the top three on my list
this actually goes for my top 10
favorite movies the top 10 best of the
year as well it's like four through ten
you can interchange some here and there
but the top three I like to think I can
look at and be like those are the top
three absolutely uncontested for me in
my list but these top three I like where
they are I like that they're the top
three because they are pieces or parts
of a franchise or otherwise execution
that is just failing entirely and misses
what made it special originally with
that vague yet semi-specific description
out of the way we come to Jurassic world
Dominion so much dumb look the original
Jurassic Park is one of my favorite
movies of all time the first Jurassic
world was a fun monster movie I got what
they were going for Jurassic world
Dominion is everything wrong with these
30 years later sequels it's actually a
movie like this is why I was scared for
a Top Gun Maverick I mean it came out
after top gun Maverick it's not the
reason why but the execution of Jurassic
world Dominion is the embodiment of why
bring back the original cast for the
sake of nostalgia hope that's enough to
keep everything afloat when they're in
the middle of this [ __ ] ass film this
was a lazy ass monster movie they
brought the original cast back didn't
know what to do with them I feel like
they kind of didn't know what to do with
the cast of the Jurassic World movies as
well it's a movie where if I was a smart
YouTube business person I would have
done a spoiler Talk video to get a few
hits out of this thing just milk it for
a little bit more I realized I just
didn't give a [ __ ] number two next up
Fantastic Beasts the secrets of dumb
boldor I'm gonna keep calling it The
Secrets of dumb just helps life make
more sense I've never been too crazy
about these fantastic Beast movies at
best it's they started out with well
that means not as good as Harry Potter
you know and they've just gone downhill
from there mads Mickelson clocked on to
work absolutely but it doesn't matter
who was Grindelwald mads Mickelson
Johnny Depp the film itself is still bad
Harry Potter is a beloved classic I
watched the movies recently enough I
want to reread the books in fact there's
a reason that those stories hit people
to their heart these fantastic Beast
movies just feel like uninspired cash
grabs
now this is the film that bothered me
just it bothered me when I watched it it
bothered me more as time went on then
Guillermo del Toro's Pinocchio crushed
it and I was like well that was inspired
the Disney live action
not at all Disney Live Action Pinocchio
this year is the embodiment of
everything wrong with Disney Live Action
take an animated beloved classic Shang
Tsung the [ __ ] out of it and sap its
soul from its body sap it of all life
and anything people loved about it then
put a bow on it and put it back out
there for redistribution done we just
made a new movie no you made gift
wrapped [ __ ] congratulations but we got
Tom Hanks to say yes
so it's funny these Disney live action
movies have just progressively gotten
worse and worse to the point where
they're clearly just phoned in I'd be
shocked if I found out there were even
scripts to these Disney live action
movies I feel like the scripts are just
Cliff Notes from the animation the
little excerpt at the bottom that says
now reinvent the wheel the live-action
Pinocchio is the wake up call to Disney
where it's like dude you gotta do it
differently
do it differently or don't do it at all
these movies are bad do they make money
oh that's right it's on Disney plus so
the answer is no but you're going to be
told yes whatever we're going to keep
getting these monstrosities it doesn't
matter they can keep doing it if they
want to they can keep making trash but
as long as they do and they are this bad
that just keeps giving me content for my
top 10 worst movies of the year list
from the mouse phoning it the [ __ ]
so that's it that's my list those are
the top 10 worst movies of 2022 or at
the very least most disappointing to me
again I want to thank you all for
watching me for another year this
channel doesn't exist without you and I
love you all for that and thank you for
watching this video as well videos like
this or the celebration of those moments
when that which should be fun feels like
work and I'll see you all in 2023 and I
feel like a lot of you are smarter than
me which you're like nope I heard that
movie [ __ ] I'm not watching it but in
case you didn't listen to that voice in
your head your top ten five three or one
worst movies of 2022. what is it what's
your list what do you think whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
foreign